nous entendons cet après-midi madame
Charlotte cobel secrétaire d'État auprès
de la première ministre chargée de
l'enfance je vous remercie madame la
ministre d'avoir accepté cette rencontre
cet après-midi on s'était déjà rencontré
un peu pour échanger lors de votre
nomination et en effet un sujet celui de
l'enfance qui est au cœur des travaux en
partie des travaux de notre commission
et
mais on sera la focalisé sur sur un
sujet plus particulier alors cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo qui sera retransmée en direct sur
le site du Sénat est disponible en vidéo
à la demande
on a inscrit en effet dans notre
programme de travail le suivi des
recommandations de la mission
d'information relatives au violon
sexuelles sur mineur en institution
c'était une mission commune
d'information que nous avons menée
maintenant 2018
19 j'en étais présidente Michel meunier
Marie Mercier et Dominique verrière on
était les co-rapportun et nous avons
souhaité avoir une évaluation de la mise
en oeuvre des recommandations de cette
mission je vous ai fait parvenir notre
premier évaluation de la mise en oeuvre
de ces recommandations et souhaiterait
vos services puissent par la suite y
répondre en complément de ce que vous
pourrez indiquer à la commission alors
certaines de ces recommandations étaient
mises en oeuvre par la loi relative à la
protection des enfants dont Bernard
bonne était le rapporteur et c'est pour
soi que c'est pourquoi j'ai souhaité que
cette audition permettent également de
faire le point sur la mise en
application de ce texte
donc madame la ministre je vous souhaite
tout de suite la parole donc de commande
MCI violence sexuelle et la loi sur le
sur l'enfant merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
d'abord effectivement de rester si
impliqué dans ces sujets d'enfance qui
évidemment m'anime aussi merci pour
cette invitation
permettez-moi bien sûr de saluer tout
d'abord la qualité du rapport de la
mission d'information sur les violences
sexuelles commisses sur les mineurs en
institution et la qualité des
recommandations et vous l'avez dit
certaines ont pu être déployés très
rapidement par le gouvernement dans le
précédent
en particulier
dans la loi du 7 février 2022 j'aurais
évidemment l'occasion de revenir dans le
détail sur les différents décrets
d'applications de ce texte et sur les
différentes démarches qui ont été mises
en oeuvre pour mettre en oeuvre ce texte
très très riche qui nous occupe
techniquement depuis mon arrivée au
gouvernement votre excellent rapport à
rejoindre celui de la siase et de la
civisme et il vient nous rappeler avec
force l'urgence la nécessité d'une prise
de conscience quand même collective sur
la réalité que subissent de trop
nombreux enfants dans notre pays je le
dis on se retrouve un petit peu en ce
début de quinquennat dans la situation
qu'on a vécu pour les violences faites
aux femmes dans le précédent quinquennat
on a du mal à ce que la mesure soit
prise par nos concitoyens et je vous
remercie de contribuer à apprendre aussi
la parole au travers de ce type de
rapport pour dire attention tous nos
enfants ne sont pas heureux tous nos
enfants ne sont pas rois et certains
subissent des choses évidemment
totalement traumatisante
de chiffres évidemment que je ne cesse
de répéter mais je le redirai encore un
enfant meurt dans le cadre familial tous
les cinq jours en France et la civisme
nous dit que 160 000 enfants sont
victimes chaque année au moins de
d'infraction sexuelles
ce qui est certain c'est qu'on se rend
compte à la lecture d'un certain nombre
de dossiers et de d'affaires judiciaires
que nous n'arrivons pas à stopper la
chaîne de reproduction des violences
nous n'arriverons pas à casser la chaîne
de reproduction des inégalités sociales
mais pas non plus celle des violences
qu'elles soient intrafamiliales et
qu'elles soient sexuelle on le constate
très souvent les criminels d'aujourd'hui
ont été les victimes d'hier et ça ne
peut que nous interroger effectivement
de manière très forte vous le dites dans
votre rapport et c'est une de mes
difficultés sur lequel je vais essayer
de travailler un manque de données
statistiques extrêmement fort
voilà on a un constat partagé par
différentes auditions par des
prospections mais on manque quand même
de donner pour des raisons à la fois
liées aux statistiques justice mais
aussi évidemment à de nombreuses
infractions qui ne sont pas révélées ou
qui n'arrivent pas jusqu'à la justice
et puis derrière évidemment l'absence de
donner juste il n'est pas toujours
facile d'avoir une stratégie claire et
partagée puisque il nous faut quand même
des données pour pouvoir travailler face
assez constat notre détermination est
sans faille la première ministre à
l'occasion du comité interministériel de
l'enfance qui s'est tenu le 21 novembre
a mis en priorité une la lutte contre
les violences commises sur les mineurs
donc ça reste évidemment d'une grande
actualité avec tous les points qui sont
très bien présentés dans votre rapport
la nécessité de travailler la
connaissance des réalités
des situations et de leurs conséquences
toujours aussi travailler sur le
psychotroma et la façon dont on prend en
charge les enfants évidemment très
important
la prévention et la formation des
professionnels qui accompagnent nos
enfants quels qu'ils soient ou qu'ils
soient le repérage et l'accompagnement
des enfants victimes et la lutte contre
la récidive avec l'accompagnement des
auteurs ou des personnes qui pourraient
être auteurs
évidemment vous rien qu'en lisons tout
ça vous voyez bien que je n'ai pas le
monopole de cette action mais par contre
c'est mon positionnement près de la
première ministre qui peut me permettre
j'espère d'actionner tous les leviers
pour faire avancer tous ces sujets nous
avons donc en effet des outils très
opérationnels pour mettre en oeuvre
cette politique prioritaire je l'ai dit
le comité interministériel de l'enfance
à l'occasion de celui du 21 novembre
nous avons annoncé la création d'un
office central dédié aux violences
faites aux enfants et notamment aux
affaires les plus complexes cette Office
qui sera créée en début d'année sera
accompagné d'une circulaire de politique
pénale portée par le garde des sceaux
mais nous avons aussi fait beaucoup de
choses dans le plan de lutte contre les
violences que faites aux enfants 2020
2022 annoncé par Adrien taquet mais qui
était le fruit d'un large concertation
avec les associations les chercheurs les
experts les professionnels du secteur
tous les ministères y étaient impliqués
je dois dire que 19 des 22 mesures de
son plan de ce plan ont été mis en
oeuvre en deux ans saluons on a beaucoup
de plans au gouvernement qui n'ont pas
nécessairement ce succès actuellement
mes équipes sont en train de formaliser
le bilan de ce plan que nous vous
transmettrons en même temps que le
tableau que vous nous avez remis donc
quand même quelque chose de très très
efficace qui
correspond à peu près globalement enfin
en tout cas peu ou pro recommandations
que vous avez faites voilà alors je
voulais aussi évidemment rentrer
peut-être un peu dans le détail de
quelques actions avant de répondre point
par points aux préconisations on vous
indiquant que s'agissant par exemple de
la prévention et de l'amélioration du
repérage des situations violences
sexuelles d'abord le ministère
d'éducation nationale et l'ensemble des
acteurs de ministériel ont remis une
nouvelle fois au travail la question de
l'éducation sexuelle et de la
l'éducation à la vie affective et de la
prévention des infractions sexuelles à
l'école on demande beaucoup à notre
école mais ce sujet là reste quand même
un sujet récurrent on sait que ces deux
heures obligatoires faites pas imposés
par la loi ne sont pas bien mis en
oeuvre donc là le travail est remis à
nouveau sur sur enfin on remet les
choses au travail pour à la fois
stabiliser les contenus mais aussi avoir
les acteurs nécessaires il y a eu toute
une démarche de labellisation des
associations pour qu'on évidemment cette
sensibilisation et cette formation des
enfants et mon objectif à moi c'est
démarrer peut-être encore plus tôt et
d'accompagner cette éducation à la
sexualité de l'éducation à la
parentalité qui pour moi serait
évidemment un facteur de prévention
notamment de l'inceste nous avons bien
sûr comme vous le préconisiez ren les
moyens du 119 qui ont augmenté et nous
avons pris beaucoup beaucoup de de
moyens pour renforcer la visibilité on a
fait une grande campagne de promotion de
ce numéro et des deux autres numéros qui
sont en 18 et le 30/20 pour d'autres
types de violence à la rentrée scolaire
et normalement les trois numéros sont
sur les espaces numériques des enfants
donc ils ont leur bulletin de notes et
le 119 qui sont affichés sont parce que
on voulait mettre ça dans les carnets
scolaires mais les carnets scolaires
n'existent plus mesdames et messieurs
donc on l'a mis sur l'espace numérique
voilà nous avons effectivement augmenter
les effectifs du snated donc le fameux
service national d'écoute des enfants en
danger à la fois d'ailleurs sur le sujet
des violences à proprement dites enfin
de tout type de dangers mais aussi sur
le sujet de la prostitution des mineurs
le snacket vient d'intégrer les enjeux
de prostitution des mineurs au-delà de
cette campagne lancée en début d'année
2022 qui avait d'ailleurs succédé à une
campagne qui avait eu aussi en 2021 nous
ferons en début d'année 2023 une grande
campagne sur les violences sexuelles
alors là encore plus large la campagne
119 avait visé sur tous les enfants la
campagne que nous souhaitons faire sur
les violences sexuelles sera tout public
en ce compris les enfants vous m'avez
peut-être entendu dire dans les médias
les parents pardon entendu dire dans les
médias que bien sûr il faut entendre les
enfants libérer leurs paroles mais il
faut surtout libérer la parole des
adultes au sein des familles au sein des
des professionnels et c'est eux qui
doivent prendre la responsabilité de
protéger les enfants et pas les enfants
d'avoir la responsabilité de parler
c'est pour répondre un peu au MiTo des
enfants moi je pense que c'est surtout
les adultes qui doivent se saisir de ce
sujet nous avons pris en compte les
préconisations de la civisme et sera
créé en 2023 une plateforme d'écoute des
professionnels qui peuvent faire face à
des révélations plus ou moins complètes
de violences sexuelles
et qui ne sont pas toujours armés pour
pour voir répondre à ce type de
révélation je pense à la maîtresse
d'école qui peut constater un certain
nombre de choses et qui peut se
retrouver en conflit de loyauté avec la
maman ou le papa qui va venir chercher
les enfants qui peut être pardonnez-moi
au conseil municipal du même village
avec le papa ou aller à gym avec maman
et qui se retrouve en difficulté parce
qu'elle n'est pas tout à fait sûre et
elle va se dire je suis pas la mieux
placée pour en parler je pense aux
professeur de danse au professeur de
dans le monde sportif je pense aussi au
médecin et à toute champ de la médecine
libérale enfin du soin libéral où on ne
peut que constater aujourd'hui quand
même la faiblesse du nombre de
signalements on sait et vous l'avez
évoqué que nous avons une situation
regarde du secret professionnel mais je
pense que au delà même de cet obstacle
que je considère comme relatif et cette
sont aussi vos conclusions on a un sujet
de detaiement de des signaux et de
conforter les repérage fait par les
professionnels et de leur donner
finalement ce petit courage et parfois
simplement le numéro et le processus
pour pouvoir voilà et d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour dire que cette plateforme
sera aussi articulée notamment dans le
champ de la médecine avec les yeux à
peine qui remplissent déjà pour beaucoup
ce rôle de conseils auprès de la
médecine libérale voilà donc un
accompagnement des professionnels à
noter que les formations on y reviendra
peut-être dans vos questions ont été
fortement renforcées à l'école enfin au
sein de l'éducation nationale ont été
renforcés aussi évidemment dans les
services d'enquête et de police et que
nous nous saisirons
du très beau guide de la formation des
professionnels qui a été produit par la
civisme et qui est extrêmement bien fait
et qu'il faut évidemment prendre en
compte nous travaillons bien sûr dans le
champ de la foi là de la prévention sur
le contrôle systématique des antécédents
judiciaires de tous les professionnels
c'était déjà le cas mais aussi des
bénévoles dans le champ de l'enfance et
du contrôle du fijse vous le savez que
le figé c'est un peu plus compliqué
parce que le sujet s'il y a des
dispositions qui sont dedans qui sont
qui doivent exiger un regard humain pour
en apprécier la pertinence et la
nécessité de bloquer un contrat de
travail par rapport à tout ça donc la
loi est claire l'obligation est en
vigueur depuis le 1er novembre dernier
nous sommes en train de finaliser un
dispositif qui va bientôt voir le jour
où on aura une équipe dédiée nationale
pour interroger les services du casier
judiciaire quasiment en temps réel
puisqu'il est évidemment un objectif ne
pas freiner les contrats en matière
notamment de protection de l'enfance ni
de freiner les initiatives des bénévoles
en attendant trop longtemps ce type
d'interrogations donc un dispositif très
opérationnel qui sera d'abord très
centrée sur le champ du travail social
et les bénévoles dans le champ du
travail social et qui j'espère absorbera
finalement à terme ce qui est déjà fait
par l'Éducation nationale et par le
ministère des Sports finalement tous les
acteurs qui sont en contact avec les
enfants on estime à plusieurs millions
de personnes à criblées quand même c'est
pas une petite affaire cette obligation
qui a été mise dans la loi sont étude
d'impact donc c'est évidemment une
grosse une grosse pression pour les
équipes mais elle ça sera en oeuvre
c'est une évidemment une excellente une
excellente disposition dans les
dispositions qui ont aussi beaucoup
avancé dans vos propositions notamment
la numéro 4 l'écoute de la parole de
l'enfant victime alors on le sait on le
sait enfin c'est en tout cas ma
perception que je partage avec vous il y
a eu un phénomène de de glaciation des
acteurs notamment policiers et
judiciaire après outre il y a eu quand
même vraiment clairement il y a eu
l'effet outro qui a qui a un peu freiné
en tout cas qui a effrayé une partie et
je sais vraiment de quoi je parle parce
que moi-même j'ai été chargée de ce type
d'enquête
à cette époque donc il y a eu vraiment
un effet trop
il faut bien l'admettre et c'est très
bien le combat porté par la voix de
l'enfant en poussant les yeux à peine
est un combat qui est un qui a été
salutaire et les USA Pets sont des lieux
donc unité d'accueil pédiatrique sont
des lieux absolument
Jean-Paul mot extraordinaire qui
aujourd'hui permet d'écouter avec
attention les enfants et l'environnement
familial quand il n'est pas lui-même
évidemment auteur des faits et
d'accompagner les parents qui dénoncent
et d'éviter évidemment comme vous le
savez les doubles les doubles
expressions etc ce sont des lieux des
ressources vraiment tout à fait à
privilégier c'est pourquoi avec le
garder sauts de la santé en septembre
nous avons évidemment
décidé de aller au-delà des 60 tu
appelles qui étaient déjà en cours et de
d'arbitrer bien sûr pour que tous les
départements soient dotés du uaped à
horizon de début 2024 et nous
travaillerons après s'il en est besoin à
deux appels dans les appartements où
nous avons des gros juridictions ou des
grosses populations ou plusieurs
juridictions donc vraiment une priorité
juste pour information mais peut-être ça
sera dans vos questions bien sûr les
uapathes s'articulent avec les fameuses
sales Mélanie des services d'enquêtes
l'idée étant d'avoir un maillage de lieu
privilégiés et de personnes formées et
avec un vrai dialogue entre les services
d'enquête les services judiciaires et
les professionnels de santé qui
accompagnent ces enfants c'est une
richesse qu'il nous faut préserver je
tiens à dire aussi que nous
travaillerons avec ces appels sur la
question justement des données pour
pouvoir les approfondir voilà déjà
quelques points mais je pense que vos
questions seront nombreuses je voulais
aussi vous dire que dans le cadre des du
conseil intermittel de l'enfance nous
avons quatre autres points le deuxième
recouvre une partie de vos
préconisations c'est la prise en charge
des personnes des enfants les plus
vulnérables les enfants de l'aseu avec
tout un plan autour de l'ASE et
notamment des institutions
nous mettrons en oeuvre dès le début du
mois de janvier deux choses importantes
bien sûr le Jeep enfance protégé dont
l'arrêté sorti à quelques jours et qui
connaîtra ses premières actions à partir
du 1er janvier mais aussi les conseils
départementaux de protection de
l'enfance qui sont des organes de
gouvernance ou nous devons pouvoir état
et départements le département restant
évidemment chef de fil mais l'état quand
j'ai l'État c'est la justice l'éducation
la santé le point a piloté par le préfet
et l'autorité judiciaire pour
accompagner les départements dans la
prise en charge de ces enfants parce que
sont l'état les départements sont
parfois quand même démuni face à un
certain nombre de situations ça sera
l'occasion notamment et ça rejoint vos
préconisations de renforcer le contrôle
des établissements et des services et de
vérifier par exemple que le contrôle
figeste et B2 et fait systématiquement
donc très important pour nous des
priorités deux autres priorités la santé
des enfants et la protection au
numérique mais on est loin des mais en
tout cas c'est évidemment une priorité
du gouvernement cinquième point le
service national de la petite enfance
qui est une réponse avec un enjeu
d'égalité des l'homme et de la femme
devant le travail mais aussi un enjeu de
prévention et d'accompagnement des
enfants y compris les plus fragiles y
compris les enfants victimes
d'infraction sexuelles voilà je suis à
votre disposition merci madame la
ministre en effet pour revenir un peu
sur l'introduction ce qui nous semble
important au sein de notre commission
c'est lorsque des rapports importants je
pense qu'en effet la mission commune
d'information avait fait très très beau
rapport et cellules rapporteur et
notamment Michel meunier sur ce sujet
des violences sexuelles sur mineur en
institution on a vu après ce qu'a fait
également concernant l'église qui était
un des volets de cette mission
d'information que ça a eu des suites
vraiment considérables mais ce qui est
important c'est aussi qu'on voit au fil
du temps comment les préconisations sont
faites parce c'est bien de faire des
beaux rapports mais s'ils ne sont pas
mis en application ça limite bien
évidemment leur impact moi j'avais une
première question vous avez parlé de la
vérification des des antécédents
judiciaires des professionnels au
contact des enfants notamment au moyen
du figeste et on avait plusieurs
recommandations à ce sujet alors en
cohérence avec la préconisation numéro
14 de notre rapport nous avions voté au
sein de la loi relative à protection de
l'enfance mais Bernard bonne en parlera
peut-être le renforcement de l'arsenal
législatif et notamment l'article 20 qui
rend obligatoire la consultation du
figeste pour le recrutement de toute
personne travaillant en contact de
mineur dans le secteur socio-e
médico-sociaux y compris les bénévoles
et travailler occasionnels vous l'avez
évoqué
est-ce qu'il y a des mesures
particulières pour faire respecter les
contrôles dans les établissements
accueillants des enfants handicapés on
avait vu qu'il y avait une fragilité
toute particulière des enfants en
situation de handicap par rapport aux
violences qu'il subir
et on avait été un peu étonné lorsqu'on
avait fait notre mission aussi de la
difficulté qui avait les associations de
venir parler de cette situation
particulière du handicap ça avait été
très compliqué de faire des auditions
est-ce que c'était par une crainte en
effet que les places étant tellement
cher que
entre guillemets tellement cher que
certains parents craignaient peut-être
mais c'est vrai que ça avait été très
compliqué Michel s'en souvient cette
notion de travailler sur ce secteur
alors qu'on sait que ces enfants sont
particulièrement vulnérables il y avait
une plateforme unique au secteur social
de consultation des antécédents
judiciaires qui est annoncée c'est ça
c'est ce oui
deux observations sur notre question
elle a la présidente la première
évidemment
un quart des enfants placés ont son
porteur de handicap donc pour nous c'est
ça donc selon les situations entre un
quart et 33% avec donc une grande
fragilité et on sait comme le facteur
handicap et parfois un accélérateur de
passage à l'acte dans les agressions
sexuelles je pense notamment aux enfants
autistes qui sont très souvent
statistiquement plus plus vulnérable aux
agressions sexuelles donc évidemment un
public sur lequel on sera extrêmement
attentif
l'obligation pour moi elle s'applique
évidemment elle aussi alors elle
s'appliquait le le
casier judiciaire c'est la question du
figeste à l'ensemble des établissements
médico-sociaux la question c'est
aujourd'hui la plateforme parce que
évidemment on a un fort en jeu qui est
de n'oublier personne de cribler tout le
monde pardonnez-moi cette expression un
peu services de renseignement on va
faire de cribler tout le monde et pour
autant de ne pas freiner ni les
recrutements ni les projets avec les
bénévoles etc je veux dire Noël c'est
maintenant le Père Noël on va pas le
cribler dans trois mois donc il faut
effectivement c'est ça quand même l'idée
c'est cette Crimée le Père Noël quand il
entre dans l'établissement donc il faut
vraiment y arriver les clous etc donc on
a créé un dispositif aujourd'hui centré
avec les départements parce que ce sont
les premiers acteurs de de l'accueil des
enfants et notre idée c'est déjà de bien
mettre ça bien opérationnel et d'élargir
très très vite sur la plateforme mais
l'obligation elle existe et si et donc
c'est juste que ça sera du direct entre
les employeurs et les services du casier
judiciaire là nous là où nous on cherche
à industrialiser par cette plateforme
pour que ça aille très très vite voilà
mais on les rentrera dans le dispositif
industriel le plus rapidement possible
je vous rejoins c'est toute la richesse
de nos établissements médico-sociaux
c'est que le champ du handicap à
plusieurs tutelles et que les situations
ne sont pas toujours très simples à
gérer voilà
ma deuxième question elle portait sur
l'attestation de non-inscription figeste
et concernant les assistantes maternelle
pour chaque personne majeure ou mineur
âgée d'au moins 13 ans vivant en
domicile de demandeur parce qu'on a eu
en effet des exemples de d'agression
sexuelle qui se faisaient soit par le
conjoint ne sauvent paternel soit par
les enfants l'assistante maternelle ça a
été mis dans le projet de loi relatif à
protection de l'enfance
est-ce qu'il y a une application déjà
dans les départements ma deuxième
deuxième point c'était une couverture
territoriale équilibrée dans le
déploiement des centres de prise en
charge de psycho-traumatisme avec la
nécessité d'atteindre une centaine de
structures à terme alors en 2019 il y
avait 10 centres régionaux du psycho
traumatisme qui ont été créés le plan de
lutte gouvernement a prévu que soit
opérationnel 5 CRP supplémentaires en
2022 est-ce vous pouvez nous donner un
peu si ces chiffres ont été atteints
s'il y a des appels à projets en cours
et si quel est le maillage et enfin on
avait évoqué aussi dans dans notre dans
notre mission les les personnes attirer
sexuellement par les enfants on était
allé à
Lyon où il y a une prise en charge des
délinquants de l'incon sexuel sur des
pédocrinels
nous on souhaitait une étude
criminologique approfondie sur les
déterminants si on peut les trouver
déterminants de ce passage à l'acte ce
qui n'a pas été fait à notre
connaissance avec en dépit d'un objectif
annoncé développer la recherche à ce
sujet en revanche c'est vrai que
parallèlement à ce qui existait c'est en
Allemagne je crois de ce numéro d'appel
pour les personnes attirer sexuellement
par des enfants une permanence d'écoute
je pense que ça ça a pu prospérer en
France et c'est une une mesure dont nous
réjouissons voilà pour pour solutions je
vous laisse peut-être répondre à ça et
ensuite nous offrons des collègues alors
l'obligation de cribler les familles
d'accueil en se compris les personnes
habitant avec la famille d'accueil
en se compris les mineurs de plus de 13
ans était d'abord effectivement depuis
le 1er novembre donc et donc elle elle
rentre en vigueur et va être
systématisée au moment du recrutement la
question c'est la reprise du stock qui
va avoir qui va être facilité par deux
leviers la plateforme dont je parle et
surtout par la création du fichier des
assistantes familiales et familiaux des
assistants familiaux qui fait partie des
nouvelles missions du Gyp France en
France protégé le budget que vous avez
adopter contient des ressources
financières pour faire au plus vite ce
fichier qui est une des nouvelles
missions du Gyps françois-force protégée
donc le fichier va nous permettre de
bien recenser l'ensemble des assistants
familiaux et de partir de là pour
recribbler les l'ensemble des assistants
familiaux avec quand même toujours bon
une fragilité c'est que par définition
ce sont des vrais familles ou les
enfants viennent et repartent et oui il
faudra donc
assurer quand même un suivi et régulier
bon on fera le mieux ça sera pas une un
maillage nécessairement tout à fait
parfait mais ce sera déjà mieux
qu'aujourd'hui où on sait pas la
situation voilà alors s'agissant
effectivement des centres de psychotroma
pour moi les 10 centres et les plus
simples oui c'est la préconisation 30 la
ligne 34 voilà donc ça vous l'aurez dans
le tableau mais les centres ont été
créés et je dirais que donc les 10
centres ont été créés en 2019 et 5
supplémentaires ont été créés en 2020
réunion Normandie Bretagne Pays de la
Loire et nouvelle Aquitaine ils ont un
volet adulte et un volet enfant et
adolescents et des assure donc la prise
en charge des victimes de tous types de
violence
il y a eu bien sûr vos préconisations
mais la question de la prise en charge
notamment des mineurs de retour de zones
de toute façon accéléré le développement
de ces cellules de précis autrement
voilà donc oui elles sont elles sont
effectivement en fonction évidemment
très utile et voilà alors s'agissant de
la prise en charge des des personnes
susceptibles de passer à l'acte ou
d'être passé à l'acte on s'est
évidemment rendu compte que grâce aux
criards ces centres de ressources
d'infraction des auteurs de violences
sexuelles que de deux choses d'abord que
nous étions un peu retard par rapport à
d'autres pays je pense notamment à la
Belgique sur ce sujet là et d'autre part
que après un certain sondage un sondage
certains auteurs disaient qu'ils avaient
appelé au secours et que personne ne les
avait entendus donc on a on a un numéro
d'écoute qui a été largement alors qui
est que je trouve pas très lisible je
suis incapable d'ailleurs de vous dire
les chiffres dans le bon ordre que je
trouve pas très lisible mais il y a
aussi un chat qui a été mis en place on
essaye au maximum ça fait partie des
objectifs qui ont été mis dans le plan
de lutte contre les violences et sur
lequel on reste extrêmement attentif en
lien évidemment avec toute la politique
qui conduit par le ministre de la
Justice sur la prise en charge des
auteurs récidives etc voilà
et pardon excusez-moi nous aurons une
audition en la réalisation en 2023 2024
d'une audition publique sur les mineurs
auteurs de violences sexuelles donc il
est porté pas notamment la PJJ on vue
d'optimiser la prise en charge et la
prévention des violences sexuelles des
mineurs et d'améliorer la pratique des
professionnels vous savez que quand on
parle d'inceste on a quand même souvent
de l'inceste entre mineurs ou entre
entre fratries ou entre je sais pas si
on dit Cousinerie bon en tout cas cette
question de l'infraction commise par les
mineurs sur les mineurs est un enjeu
très important au sein des familles mais
évidemment au sein des institutions vous
savez que c'est vraiment un des risques
assez important et quand j'ai envie de
quelques-unes je quand même attentif à
tout ce qui concerne l'intimité des
enfants on a encore un peu tendance au
nom de il risque d'avoir peur s'il dort
tout seul de nous faire des chambres un
peu collectives c'est vraiment un sujet
important
merci beaucoup alors maintenant je vais
passer la parole à Bernard bonne ensuite
Michel meunier Laurence Cohen Colette
après pour la deuxième partie parce que
la première partie était sur les
violences sexuelles la deuxième partie
est sur la mission le rapport peut-être
en deuxième partie je poserai mes
questions du rapport sur les violences
Michel c'était sur cette partie là si
madame la Présidente merci Madame la
Ministre lorsque vous êtes venu à Nantes
c'était la dernière fois à l'occasion
d'une journée de formation des
professionnels du département sur le
repérage justement donc c'était l'objet
de ma première question mais vous y avez
bien répondu à la formation
professionnelle et à l'indispensable
formation de ces professionnels pour
connaître parce que sans connaissance
par pas d'action ça on le sait et sans
le repérage des signaux que les
tout-petits peuvent émettre que les
grands peuvent dire bref il faut des
professionnels formés et des
professionnels qualifiés donc je passe
ma première question ma deuxième
question concernait les U et vous y avez
là aussi
répondu en partie moi je voulais savoir
quantitativement où est-ce qu'on en est
quand on avait fait le travail il y
avait à peu près 58 unités pour enfants
victimes en France en 2019 je ne sais
pas si ou est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui si vous aviez des
informations et puis j'ai une question
qui concerne la protection de ceux qui
signale notamment les médecins donc dans
le travail qu'on avait fait on avait vu
que il y avait pas rien mais c'était
très flou et même Jean-Marc Sauvé le
convenait lui-même enfin il faudrait je
pense repréciser les choses sur les
obligations de signalement en tout cas
protéger aussi ce qui signale et donc
j'en veux pour preuve les deux médecins
pédopsychiatres là qui ont été condamnés
très récemment par leur ordre
et ça c'est problématique parce que on
sait que c'est une des raisons qui
d'abord qui continue à malmener les
enfants victimes et à protéger les
agresseurs c'est donc là je j'aimerais
votre point de vue madame les ministres
est-ce que vous comptez faire pour
clarifier notre droit là-dessus et puis
une autre question qui concerne le
figeste mais du point de vue de la
vérification des antécédents des adultes
qui interviennent sur les mineurs donc
ça a été redit par notre président
l'article 20 de la loi de février 2022 a
recommandé la généralisation
de la consultation figes pour les
professionnels pour les bénévoles
également et je vous laisse savoir ce
qu'il en est de la systématisation et du
renforcement des contrôles pour les
personnes qui sont chargées des
transports scolaires ou des transports
habituels pour les mineurs en soins
qu'est-ce qu'il en est exactement
comment est-ce qu'on s'assure de
l'honorabilité des intervenants dans ce
secteur et quels sont les procédures
d'agrément ou d'habilitation les
concernant je remercie de ces réponses
pour ces collègues inscrits Laurence
Cohen Colette mélo Pascal il est mouillé
il y a des questions qui concernent ces
violences alors Laurence Cohen
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
Madame la Ministre moi j'aimerais
peut-être avoir un peu plus de de
précision concernant les la protection
en fait des des jeunes des enfants des
adolescents qui sont porteurs d'un
handicap vous l'avez un peu dit mais
effectivement il y a eu une enquête qui
a été lancée par le parquet de Chartres
un contre une une société privée
vous-même vous avez lancé un audits et
j'aimerais bien avoir un peu d'éléments
par rapport est-ce que bon le dit tu vas
prendre un certain je ne sais pas
combien de temps mais vous allez nous le
dire donc comment qu'elles vont être les
suites qui vont pouvoir être apportées
c'est ma première question sur cette
question précisément des violences etc
vous l'avez un peu suggéré mais est-ce
qu'il y a pas juste que le fait de ce
qu'il y ait un en cheval va être des
responsabilités en plus entre plusieurs
on va dire secrète Taria des tas est-ce
que ça n'est pas finalement un peu lourd
d'un point de vue administratif et ce
qu'il ne faudrait pas qu'il y ait qu'un
qu'une responsabilité pour permettre de
d'avoir peut-être un peu une
simplification des des choses la
deuxième la deuxième question troisième
question c'est concernant la la
prostitution des mineurs donc c'est un
sujet que nous avons nous avons abordé
que ce soit au niveau de la commission
des affaires sociales que ce soit au
niveau de la délégation aussi au droit
des femmes et la dernièrement avec notre
rapport aussi
concernant la pornographie nous avons eu
aussi à l'aborder avec plusieurs
collègues puisqu'on était quatre co-
rapporteurs et dans la commission des
affaires sociales donc Laurence
Rossignol et moi-même mais moi ce qui ce
qui est venu puisque hier il y avait une
table ronde à l'Assemblée nationale il y
a une les filles une survivante de la
prostitution comme elle s'est présentée
et qui a expliqué que elle était mineure
elle a été exposée effectivement à de la
pornographie et que bon du coup elle a
été entraînée dans un réseau de
prostitution et donc moi j'aimerais
avoir votre
enfin vos interventions possibles
précisément sur les mineurs sur cette
question là je vous ai entendu dans une
émission de radio où vous avez dit
clairement les choses mais voilà après
il faut effectivement quelle dispositif
vous disposez et en corrélation c'est
sur la zone on a quand même recueilli
beaucoup de témoignages concernant des
enfants qui avaient été qui était à
l'âgeeux et qui avait subi énormément de
violence et encore hier à cette même
table ronde on nous a reconfirmé
et bien il y avait des
rabatteurs on va dire devant les hôtels
et qui attendaient les jeunes jeunes
filles et jeunes garçons pour
effectivement les entraîner dans un
parcours de prostitution donc je
voudrais là aussi qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce que
l'État fait et pour ne pas reprendre la
parole et ça va être un lien entre les
deux les deux parties du rapport je me
demande quand même s'il faut pas
remettre à plat complètement la zone qui
me semble-t-il
voilà c'est fondre un peu ou en tout cas
il y a quelque chose quel que soit la
bonne volonté l'intervention des
départements je remets pas du tout du
tout ça en cause mais je pense là il y a
quelque chose qui qui va pas trop bien
je vous laisse peut-être répondre parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de questions ensuite
oui parce que alors
c'est d'être bref surtout le suivi
ah pardon excuse non non mais c'est pour
toi donc on peut
[Musique]
finirai par l'apothéose qu'il a
effectivement alors à ce stade on compte
135 appels et projet du happy identifié
dans les ARS donc on est aujourd'hui à
56 appâts conformes au cahier des
charges 19
uaped a accompagné dans la mise en
conformité des cahiers des charges soit
tu appelles en projet voilà donc ça
c'est très concrètement il reste six
départements à couvrir qui n'ont pas
encore de projet et sur lequel vous
pouvez compter sur l'engagement de la
présidente Martin Bruce pour les
poursuivre nuit et jour pour qu'ils
ouvrent les envies voilà et elle fait
bien tellement comme je le répète c'est
évidemment très important la question du
secret médical nous partageons avec le
ministre de la Santé et avec vous
Sauveur de ma part que les textes en
vigueur aujourd'hui ne sont pas un
obstacle à la révélation la loi voilà ce
qui est plus perturbant c'est le code de
déontologie notamment des médecins mais
c'est celui que je connais
qui nous met de la super prudence un peu
partout avec beaucoup de prudence avec
énormément de prudence et encore plus de
prudence ce qu'on peut à la fois
évidemment comprendre le on est content
que nos médecins soient prudent
évidemment mais qui probablement
constitue à la fois un blocage personnel
et des jurisprudences évidemment
aujourd'hui surprenante notons quand
même que le Conseil d'État dans une
décision récente et revenue sur une
condamnation d'une infirmière et que sur
cette base là le ministre de la Santé et
moi-même entendons ouvrir un dialogue
avec les ordres pour leur demander
d'être nettement plus clair dans leur
position afin que s'il maintenait cette
jurisprudence ce qui paraît difficile
par rapport au Conseil d'État mais enfin
voilà on se positionne nous
définitivement faut-il un texte ou par
un texte voilà en gros on sait qu'un
texte servirait finalement à clarifier
quelque chose qui nous considère comme
étant résultats du droit mais si on
reste dans
une une incompréhension des enjeux on va
dire ça comme ça entre les ordres et
nous-mêmes il faudra peut-être que les
acteurs prennent sa responsabilité et
rappelle le
l'ordre des priorités peut-être l'ordre
l'ordre des valeurs même si nous sommes
évidemment tous fortement attachés au
secret médical cette question de
clarification donc est tout à fait
essentielle on s'en est saisis avec le
la santé le deuxième sujet c'est quand
même de nouveau d'accompagner et c'est
là où on rejoint le rôle des updes et le
rôle de la plateforme qu'on veut mettre
en oeuvre ces fameux
intervenants libéraux que ce soit des
infirmiers des infirmières on pense
aussi au kiné alors là je parle dans le
sens du secret professionnel médical
pour quand ils ont un doute justement
avoir un appel une plateforme
téléphonique nationale qui leur dit non
mais là de vous inquiétez pas vu les
enjeux pas de difficulté avec votre
secret médical pour passer ce cap parce
qu'après tout le monde est pas censé
connaître la jurisprudence du Conseil
donc un vrai enjeu et un enjeu bien sûr
de formation j'ai pu échanger avec le
directeur de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie on a aussi des
vecteurs pour toucher assez rapidement
l'ensemble des acteurs de santé la CNAM
fait évidemment un travail formidable
sur ça dès qu'on aura un tout petit peu
stabilisé nos échanges avec les ordres
on ira un peu plus franchement et si le
dialogue n'est pas totalement conclusif
donc on viendra vers vous législateur
pour pour peut-être donner un petit coup
de pouce alors vaste oui alors sur le
sujet alors très concrètement comme je
le disais tout à l'heure la disposition
prise dans la loi du 7 février 2022
concerne en stock plusieurs millions de
travailleurs donc déjà je veux dire il
faut quand même derrière on a la
sous-direction du casier judiciaire à
Nantes qui va devoir absorber en stock
un contrôle du fige puisqu'on faisait le
B2 mais du figes avec je répète une
vraie différence entre le B2 et le figé
au fig grâce à l'évolution de la loi
2020 il y a des il y a des dispositions
qui sont des enfin il y a des
informations qui sont du type enquêtes
ouvertes en quête classée sans suite
donc on n'est pas sur un casier ou c'est
une condamnation définitive avec une
peine et des éléments juridiques
définitifs d'où l'importance que quand
quelqu'un est positif pardonnez-moi on
dit du hypnoïde en bon français positif
ou figeste il faut que le casier
judiciaire les services du casier
judiciaire
établissent si vraiment il y a atteint
tout non à la probité et vérifie auprès
de la juridiction si la fameuse affaire
en cours a évolué si elle est classée
etc donc il y a nécessairement une
intervention humaine donc élargir à
l'ensemble des acteurs enfin des
professionnels qui sont en contact avec
nos enfants pardonnez-moi mais je
pourrais mettre les infirmières en
service pédiatrique je pourrais enfin je
veux dire là on risque de faire de noyer
et pardonnez-moi le dispositif notre
position à nous c'est mettons déjà en
œuvre la loi qui est déjà assez
conséquente du 7 février 2022 ayant un
dispositif qui va consister en fait à ce
que chaque personne qui veut être
bénévole ou employée demande un
certificat de probité
voilà donnera habilité pardonnez-moi ça
va répondre aux questions donc c'est
néant quoi enfin comme voilà comme un
test covid néant donc là vous pouvez
vous en prévaloir et si ça dit pas des
Han il faut toute une démarche voilà qui
sera effectivement individualisée donc
ce dispositif bon bah voilà la loi est
le 7 février 2022 il y a une période un
peu complexe évidemment pour les
administrations pendant le
renouvellement du gouvernement on est à
l'oeuvre pour que cette plateforme soit
en soit mise en place effectivement on
est en train de recruter une dizaine de
personnes dédiées à ça dès le 1er
janvier en tout cas le plus rapidement
possible des bulles 2023 dès qu'elle
sera très effective on pourra
s'autoriser à augmenter le nombre de
professionnels en se compris les
transporteurs etc mais j'insiste des
gens qui travaillent au contact de nos
enfants on en a quand même un bon nombre
et voilà donc on n'aura jamais pardonné
moi l'infaillibilité de ce contrôle vous
avez évoqué madame le sujet du handicap
grand sujet dont nous sommes saisis à
bras le corps avec avec Geneviève Darius
sec je comprends alors j'ai vécu pardon
à la question beaucoup de secrétaires
d'État impliqués sur le sujet alors dans
le champ du handicap on a bien sûr le
chant des enfants mais on a aussi du
parcours de l'enfant mais croyez-moi on
a aussi le sujet du parcours de la
personne en situation de handicap juste
à la majorité ou à 21 ans puisque voilà
et le parcours handicap tout au long de
la vie est aussi important et c'est le
rôle de managériossec d'être attentive à
tout ça là où moi ma focale et sur les
enfants on est extrêmement en lien tant
le sujet aujourd'hui est pregnant
j'étais aux côtés de Madame Darius sec
et de papa Ndiaye sur le conseil
interministe de l'école inclusive
pardonne-moi le conseil de l'école
inclusive on a aujourd'hui une situation
sans rentrer dans les détails sauf si
évidemment vous voulez que je que je
rentre dans les détails d'une
augmentation des diagnostics notamment
des enfants
de enfin en syndrome autistique ou avec
un certain nombre de syndrome TDAH etc
on a probablement c'est l'objet
c'est une position qui faut étayer une
médicalisation de l'ensemble des
troubles de l'acquisition alors tous les
10 Choups on les passe dans le champ du
handicap on a un vrai sujet de
parentalité d'accompagnement à la
parentalité face à ces difficultés de
d'acquisition à l'école voir des
difficultés de comportement des parents
qui sont dépassés et des MDPH des
maisons du handicap qui vont parfois
faire
du social ou de ou du et ce n'est pas un
reproche évidemment face à des parents
dépassés par les situations vous le
savez mieux que moi on a eu une forte
pression sur le sujet des aesh à la
rentrée on est quand même maintenant la
constituer un corps aesh quand même
entier dans notre pays donc aujourd'hui
on a bien sûr un objectif répondre au
cas par cas le mieux possible et au fil
de l'eau mais quand même avoir une
approche un peu macro du sujet voilà
parce que par ailleurs la délégué
interministériale la l'autisme nous
indique qu'il y a une augmentation des
enfants qui naissent avec naissent avec
des troubles du neuro-développement donc
on a une augmentation des diagnostics
une augmentation des enfants qui
naissent avec ces problématiques il nous
faut donc avoir une feuille de route
complète sur ce sujet une feuille de
route qui est portée en partie par le
Conseil national du handicap mais croyez
moi bien je serai très vigilante parce
que une des conséquences c'est quand les
enfants sont diagnostiqués qu'ils ont
une prescription notamment d'ime des
instituts médicaux éducatifs dont on n'a
pas revu la carte parce qu'on concentrer
sur l'école inclusive et derrière mes
propos il n'y a pas de reproche voilà on
a fait on a dit les enfants doivent être
à l'école c'est un sujet d'inclusion on
n'a pas revu la carte des IME il en
manque en tout cas par rapport aux
prescriptions MDPH
on a effectivement augmenté un certain
nombre d'offres mais pas complètement
donc il nous faut mettre ça à plat et
travailler probablement à des
dispositifs nouveaux on a augmenté le
nombre d'équipes mobiles il en faut
peut-être encore plus on a inauguré une
un très beau dispositif où l'IME est à
l'école donc l'école qui se rapproche de
l'IME qui se rapproche de l'école donc
on a un vrai travail de long terme et
bien sûr de documenter l'ensemble de ces
chiffres avec une explosion des
prescriptions MDPH une explosion des
aesh qui comme vous le savez sont dans
un statut précaire etc etc donc un vrai
travail une feuille de route qui est qui
mérite de secrétaires d'État je vous le
promets vu les enjeux évidemment alors
parce que on s'aperçoit qu'on a des
placements à eux parce que des FA du
dispositif handicap avant et ça dans les
départements les plus lourds je pensais
Saint-Denis dans le Nord sortie de covid
on s'aperçoit qu'on a du placement lié à
ce que j'appelle le dépassement des
parents et donc des violences qui se
sont exercées et donc là alors là on est
évidemment dans l'échec c'est un bien
grand mot mais les dispositifs de la
zone sont pas plus préparés qu'une
classe de enfin qu'une classe pour
accueillir ce type d'enfant donc on a un
vrai déborde vers la zone qu'il faut
aujourd'hui endiguer incontestablement
vous avez évoqué dans ce dans cette
situation la question des lieux de vie
qui sont l'objet de mes préoccupations
et de ce que j'ai annoncé récemment à la
suite de l'enquête dont le Canard
Enchaîné s'est fait écho il y a quelques
jours hier voilà alors face à la
complexité d'un certain nombre de
situations d'enfants qui peuvent être
complexes parce que traumatisme dans la
famille qui peuvent être complexes parce
que handicap mâle diagnostiqué
peuvent être complexes pour toutes les
raisons que vous connaissez aussi bien
que moi face
à une évolution quand même de la
pratique éducative on est sorti des
grands établissements des grands
internats etc ce sont créés ce qu'on
appelle les lieux de vie et d'accueil
donc des structures beaucoup plus
souples qui essaient de s'adapter aux
besoins des enfants c'est très demandé
parce que effectivement sur ces enfants
on est pratiquement à un point en
éducateur pour un enfant pour pas dire
de fait deux éducateurs ou 3 pour faire
la semaine entière en semaine week-end
etc
la problématique des LVA c'est que c'est
des gens qui répondent souvent présents
très vite pour accueillir des enfants et
on a une pratique du placement en dehors
des départements on savait déjà que un
certain nombre de départements placés en
Belgique dans des structures parce
qu'elle est passé de structures en
France et là c'est créer
une offre vous l'avez dit Madame avec
parfois une très bonne conscience et une
volonté de bien faire et parfois avec un
côté un tout petit peu économique aussi
et voilà donc et de toute façon un vrai
sujet de contrôle parce qu'ils
dispersion sur le territoire et parce
que des placements qui ne se font pas
nécessairement par le département sur le
département mais d'autres départements
sur un autre département c'est le cas du
sujet de l'Eure-et-Loir le département
de l'Eure-et-Loir de connaissait pas ce
lieu de vie et les enfants qui étaient
placés venaient d'autres départements
donc le contrôle n'était pas aisé à
faire évidemment voilà alors on touche
là à deux sujets qui sont prioritaires
pour moi la question de l'autorisation
et de l'habilitation des services qui
les enfants placés compte tenu de la
variété compte tenu des problématiques
de recrutement
l'augmentation des lieux de placement
enfin je veux dire le Nord là par
exemple pour on a 10% sur certains
territoires 10% en plus de placement
depuis la crise sanitaire donc pour
répondre à cette demande la création de
service de place en urgence etc comme
toujours l'administratif l'autorisation
l'habilitation passe après le fait
d'accueillir les enfants avec toujours
une bonne volonté mais évidemment un
problème de contrôle donc
l'audit que j'ai demandé c'est demandé à
chaque département de vérifier que les
structures qu'ils avaient sur leur
département était bien autorisés
ça paraît le Béaba mais je vous promets
que à mon avis le dites va être assez
intéressant et de vérifier aussi que les
établissements dans lequel il place
leurs enfants en dehors des départements
leur envoie une autorisation voilà on a
demandé ça de manière assez urgente en
impliquant en impliquant les préfets on
va voir comment ça remonte évidemment un
certain nombre de départements ne vont
pas être très très à l'aise mais je dois
l'honnêteté de vous dire que côté
habilitation judiciaire puisque un
établissement qui accueille des enfants
placés par la justice doit être habilité
on est un peu mieux mais pas nettement
mieux parce que pourquoi parce qu'il
faut du personnel administratif que les
directions départementales ont été quand
même fortement réduites et que dans le
monde de l'enfance la prise en charge de
l'enfance est toujours prioritaire sur
les démarches administratives et ça pose
un problème c'est pourquoi dans le
budget 2023 à la fois pour assurer ses
habilitations autorisation mais aussi
pour renforcer la capacité de contrôle
de l'État j'ai demandé un renforcement
la fameuse Direction Départementale de
l'emploi du travail de la solidarité qui
sont maintenant le service qui est
auprès des préfets en charge de ce type
de d'action et la renforts des
directions départementales de la PJJ
pour accompagner les départements dans
une vraie stratégie de contrôle Adrien
taquet avait lancé quelques initiatives
avant que moi je vais compléter par une
action de l'État parce que c'est la
responsabilité de l'État d'être aux
côtés des départements pour contrôler
ces établissements nous avons pas que
des situations comme ça on a des très
belles histoires et des très beaux
services mais nous avons trop de
services qui ne sont pas contrôlés et
qui conduisent à jeter nos propres sur
tout un métier et qui contribue
probablement à désespérer un certain
nombre de professionnels qui font bien
leur métier parce qu'ils savent qu'à
côté des professionnels font mal leur
métier et que ils ne sont pas contrôlés
voilà on pourra y revenir si vous le
souhaitez vous avez beaucoup posé de
questions sur la question de la
prostitution une vraie inquiétude on a
encore eu des chiffres doubles
inquiétudes le nombre de mineurs
concernés de globalement et
effectivement la grande fragilité des
mineurs placés qu'ils soient des
replacés à la PJJ ou placer à la zone
parce que vous avez raison il y a
une forme de rabattage si on emplacement
là enfin il y a des rabatteurs ce sont
des proies pour un certain nombre de
enfin pour beaucoup d'établissements
moi-même dans mes premières visites
après mon arrivée j'étais dans un foyer
d'accueil d'urgence au nord de Paris oui
en 8 filles avaient disparu depuis deux
jours toutes les toutes ensemble
manifestement pour des mécanismes de
prostitution alors il y a eu un plan qui
a été établi sur la base un excellent
rapport fait par la procureur général de
la cour d'appel de Paris qui est en
cours d'évaluation et qui est toujours
évidemment très actif nous avons financé
une campagne de sensibilisation assez
efficace qui va être relancé nous avons
formé énormément de professionnels et
nous continuerons à former des
professionnels et là où ça va se jouer
aussi c'est l'articulation avec les
services de police et de gendarmerie
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui un enfant
qui fugue d'un établissement de la zone
le service de police et de gendarmerie
ils disent finalement c'est assez
classique prévenez-moi dans deux jours
quand il rentrera parce que évidemment
c'est quelque chose à épices qu'ils ont
beaucoup d'autres choses à faire un de
mes objectifs c'est quand même de
resserrer un tout petit peu
entre guillemets l'investissement de
tout le monde quand un enfant
s'échappe plusieurs fois et qu'il
revient on est déjà tout à fait dans le
même la même logique donc on a un vrai
sujet de prise en compte et moi j'ai
aussi un vrai sujet et je vais finir par
faire une campagne dédiée à ça
on a le sujet de la sanction des
proxénètes on a le sujet de la sanction
des consommateurs des consommateurs sur
une mineure de 15 ans ça s'appelle des
criminels et donc ça là-dessus
pardonnez-moi mais ça manque un tout
petit peu de cas de cas visuels qui
dissuaderait un paquet de gens parce que
c'est quand même ça aussi cette réalité
avec les lois que vous avez tous
adoptées en dessous de 15 ans c'est un
crime et ça je pense qu'il faut aussi
que ça passe donc la question que je me
pose avec mais mes collègues du
ministère de mystère d'intérieur du
ministère de la Justice est-ce qu'on
fait une belle affaire dont on rend bien
public ou est-ce qu'on fait une campagne
dédiée voilà avoir une relation tarifée
avec une jeune fille ou un jeune garçon
moins de 15 ans c'est un crime même si
c'est arrivé voilà alors on a encore des
interventions je rappelle qu'il nous
reste une une demi-heure
alors Colette mélo alors des questions
courtes
beaucoup de réponses mais je voudrais
simplement faire une observation
en entendant tout ce que nous avait dit
merci madame la ministre et tout ce que
mes collègues aussi y compris madame la
Présidente ont évoqué je crois que
l'essentiel c'est voilà dans la
prévention et dans la formation
et l'éducation nationale joue un rôle
aussi très important parce que bon au
niveau il y a les signalements qui
peuvent être faits et il y a l'éducation
parce que l'éducation à la sexualité je
trouve n'est pas n'est pas vraiment
fait comme elle le devrait
ni vraiment institutionnalisée enfin il
faudrait que toutes les écoles le
fassent
alors là l'éducation sexualité et vous
l'avez évoqué l'éducation à la
parentalité il y a trop de familles qui
n'ont pas vraiment la notion
les notions de ceux qui donnent se faire
ni pas se faire voilà donc c'est tout
comme vous l'avez dit Madame la Ministre
un grand besoin de formation des
personnels voilà je m'arrêterai là
Grigny oui merci même la présidente moi
justement c'est un peu dans le
prolongement de ce que Colette mélo
vient de dire concernant l'éducation
nationale
parce que là finalement on parle des cas
très difficiles des violences en fait
subissent les enfants mais il faut
toujours travailler sur la prévention
plutôt et moi j'ai voilà moi j'ai appris
que par exemple donc sur les sur les cas
de violences il y avait des
interventions tout de suite très rapides
mais en revanche sur les manquements
éducatifs et bien là très très long
c'est à dire un enfant qui n'est pas à
l'école
voilà et là c'est très très long alors
que derrière on peut trouver justement
des situations où l'enfant est voilà
maltrait maltraitée et je trouve que
c'est c'est dommage et le juge
ne fait pas
l'injonction en fait de scolariser
certainement par manque de temps aussi
mais en tout cas où le circuit est trop
long je ne sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est un sujet et la deuxième question
que je voulais vous poser aussi c'est
concernant les visites médicales
quand est-ce qu'elles sont faites est-ce
que c'est fait suffisamment
régulièrement parce que là aussi c'est
un bon moyen il y a l'école école
collège enfin
merci
mouillé ensuite prenez pas le savoir et
si vous compléter et Laurence Rossignol
bon je vais aller très vite parce que
j'aurais pu ré aborder pas mal cieux
autour du handicap et mais j'ai entendu
vos paroles qui me civilisaient bien
dans la façon dont vous voyez les choses
et c'est un message vous pourriez porter
à vos collègues du gouvernement sur sa
nombre de points tout d'abord un
pourquoi parce que je pense que le débat
sur la place des émeute est un point
essentiel
c'est un point essentiel parce que
aujourd'hui
concrètement à sa tombe de situation
sont connues les parents refusent de
porter plainte pour ne pas perdre la
peine dans les établissements c'est le
débat entre la prise en charge de l'azo
et les établissements c'est le débat
notamment aujourd'hui des bulles FSS où
nous avons diminué les nombres de
personnes ime alors qu'on exprime qu'il
y a des besoins c'est le débat
aujourd'hui des 1500 jeunes Français
exilés en Belgique pour lequel nous
avons une excellent rapport du Sénat qui
a décrit tout le système d'organisation
pour laquelle la France et l'État paie
tous les tous les mois tous les ans les
sommes dont une certaine des jeunes sur
des établissements il y a aucun suivi et
parfois même en fonction de la licence
géographique et même plus de parents et
dont vous imaginez les tel établissement
moi j'ai l'occasion de de mener une
mission et de visiter des lieux qui sont
très bien notre lieu où je pense que
c'est une grosse scandaleux avec aucun
suivi de la part de l'ARS notamment Nord
qui est en charge préalé de la sorte de
ce moment-là donc je crois qu'il y a un
vrai volet et puis en sachant que en
parallèle de ça l'État met en place un
budget de 90 millions d'euros pour gérer
les urgences que tous les ans nous
utilisons jamais il y a 90 millions
d'euros qui sont mobilisés sur le Skoda
on appelle le fond le fond d'urgence
notamment sur les départs en Belgique
dans lequel nous les utilisons pas les
nous les avons revotés dans les dans les
crédits cette année au PVF esss vous
avez ensuite vous avez ensuite un autre
élément c'est que les MDPH ne peut plus
orienter mais le système de la
psychiatrie a toujours ses portes
d'entrée direct avec la Belgique vous
voyez donc il y a tout un ordre
d'éléments pour lequel il faut
intervenir dans lequel problème de la
transversalité est essentiel autour de
tout ça et puis des remarques on a
évoqué les LSH c'est le sujet mais il y
a une vraie question de fond c'est
est-ce que c'est bien éducation
nationale aujourd'hui qui est le mieux
en charge capacité de gérer les volets
est-ce que c'est pas du tout le
médico-social par rapport à votre
thématique et je t'aimerai par un
dernier point j'ai fait j'étais amené
intervenir assez longuement les
collations de la magistrature sur la
prise en charge notamment des personnes
handicapées notamment dans les auditions
dans les prises en compte donc comment
est-ce qu'on a le handicap dans les
procédures et notamment pour les jeunes
pour les mineurs généralement il y a
aucune écoute parce que on ne sait pas
prendre en charge les coûts des jeunes
handicapés vont se poser deux
comme vous voulez
c'est le juge qui passe
c'est le juge qui place
et derrière un charge après du président
du Département d'assurer les choses et
quand ça marche bien avec le juge et le
président de département ça va tout à
fait bien mais parfois ça marche pas
bien les présidents restent les juges
changent et il faut faire attention à
tout ça deuxièmement faut rappeler un
peu l'histoire on avait tous dans les
départements me semble-t-il des services
dimensionnés à prendre en charge les
enfants en difficulté de nos
départements moi j'en avais 200 à
l'époque puis après arrivé des MNA
et ça fait que il y a eu une charge
telle avec des la plupart qui n'étaient
d'ailleurs pas mineurs que vous mettiez
ensemble qu'il a fallu faire un métier
différent et c'était au détriment des
enfants des enfants dont nous avions la
responsabilité faut pas l'oublier avec
toujours parce que c'est toujours
d'actualité c'est les mêmes problèmes
actuellement 20 ans après
ne pas oublier qu'on manque de
pédopsychiatre
c'est là les difficultés aussi qu'on
rencontre donc vous avez fort à faire
dans ce domaine là et que aussi à
travers des actions qui nous sont bonnes
comme le rapprochement des fratries
parfois mais le loup dans la bergerie
donc c'est une affaire très difficile
qu'il faut voilà c'est très très
difficile
appréhender la Belgique on a bien été
content de la trouver elle a une prise
en charge de handicap qui est différente
moi quand j'avais des enfants en
Belgique c'était 72 enfants ils sont
toujours d'ailleurs 72 jamais les
familles n'ont souhaité qu'on les
rapatrie d'autre part les établissements
étaient agréés donc on savait exactement
on avait les visiter donc c'était
réglementé c'est pas tout ou rien alors
que à contrario il y a des exemples
contraires et un dernier point je pense
qu'il faudra clarifier moi je vais faire
une campagne signaler mais pas dénoncer
signaler n'est pas dénoncé et ça va vous
faire un peu les esprits à un certain
nombre et il se sentait moins
culpabilisés de Lyon signal moi j'ai
fait mon boulot j'ai signalé à d'autres
de prendre leur responsabilité derrière
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
ça et puis voir effectivement sur le
plan légal s'il faut ou pas mais il faut
entrer dans cette stratégie je me trompe
semble-t-il pour faire en sorte que on
puisse améliorer cela dans cette prise
en charge rossignol
je me réjouis de la manière dont vous
avez évoqué la façon de traiter la
portion des mineurs et en réalité moi je
suis toujours très frappée de temps en
temps il y a des beaux procès on apprend
que les proxénètes que des jeunes
prosénètes de gamine de 15 ans qui font
20 passes 30 passes par jour dans un
appartement sont poursuivis je vois
jamais les clients jamais jamais jamais
jamais c'est quand même un véritable
problème alors
le problème est lié au fait qu'il faut
des moyens d'enquête supplémentaires
mais un petit peu voilà on peut les
chercher mais c'est surtout que
globalement c'est la boîte 2016 pas
celle sur la protection de l'enfance
celle sur le système prostitutionnel qui
n'est pas appliqué on peut pas avoir la
complaisance à l'égard du client de
majeur et dire que le client de mineur
lui est un criminel
je
suis bien d'accord avec vous dans un cas
c'est une contravention de 5e classe
dans l'autre cas c'est dans l'approche
ne serait-ce que politique de politique
pénale c'est pas possible allez dire à
des gamines aller dire à des gamines que
si pour elle c'est pas bon mais qu'à
partir de 18 ans c'est glamour c'est
impossible les clients j'avais je vous
raconte ça à l'anecdote mérite beaucoup
de s'en rappelle ici j'avais demandé de
proposer quand on a eu la loi de 2020
sur le soldat je que on considère que
non entre 15 et 18
l'achat de service sexuel auprès d'une
mineure de moins de 18 ans soit
considéré comme un viol parce que il y
avait à chaque service sexuel que m'a
répondu le garde on avait quand même pas
poursuivre des pauvres gars qui savaient
pas mais c'est ça l'ambiguïté c'est que
les pauvres gaz savent pas si elles ont
15 ans 16 ans 17 ans 19 ans et la
complaisance voilà donc moi je trouve ça
très bien mais dans la manière de
l'appréhender avec vos collègues
intérieurs et justice il faut appliquer
toute la loi parce que la loi paraîtra
de pêcher les clients au filet et dedans
on sortira des clients de mineurs voilà
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose
la deuxième chose c'est sur les éléments
que vous nous avez donnés sur
l'accroissement des troubles divers des
enfants à la question qu'on se pose
c'est pourquoi alors où en sont nos
travaux de recherche
je pense que le hcfe section en France
va sortir bientôt un rapport Ferré la
CNAM sur la médicalisation on va
s'apercevoir qu'une médicalisation
accrue probablement j'ai pas le rapport
il je sais juste qu'il existe une
médicalisation accrue précoce et de plus
en plus précoce et plus on commence tôt
plus le volume et la multiplicité des
médicaments augmente également très
probablement tout ça il y a quand même
besoin peut-être de nous mobiliser
collectivement sur les causes soit c'est
de la santé environnementale auquel cas
faut le traiter c'est une voilà soit
c'est que les gens vont tellement pas
bien tellement mal que c'est ça mais on
a on a un énorme sujet de société que
vous ne pouvez pas porter toute seule
sur vos fraises épaules même si vous
avez la carrure voilà même si vous êtes
solide c'est trop lourd pour de votre
place voilà ce que je voulais dire et
puis à le sujet j'en parlerai pas
beaucoup mais parce que de qui comme
parce que en France famille femme tout
ça c'est lié tout ce qui tout ce qui se
passe dans les séparations qui se
déroulent mal ou les enfants sont
l'otage des vengeances des pères je dis
bien
des pères et je statistique
statistiquement
majoritairement des pères parce que les
pères obtiennent beaucoup plus de la
justice que n’obtiennent les mères en
réalité dans ses affaires là parce que
il y a beaucoup de plus de merde
poursuivi pour des lignes en
présentation d'enfants parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de parce que c'est chez les
pères en droit de visiter d'hébergement
que les enfants subissent des violences
sexuelles c'est quand même beaucoup plus
rare chez les mêmes les mers même quand
il y a des conflits de garde voilà et là
on a un énorme sujet qui m'amène à finir
ma plaidoirie sur celle des juridictions
spéciales spécialisées il y a besoin que
le GIE le JAF et le parquet travaille
ensemble autour de ces familles
dysfonctionnelles et qu'on arrête de
placer des enfants parce que ce parce
que la famille dysfonctionne déjà qu'on
est services d'azo vont pas bien en plus
on place des gamins uniquement parce que
le couple parental est jugé comme
dysfonctionnant
dysfonctionnel pardon au regard des de
certains juges
très bien alors je répondais il y avait
des observations quelques questions et
puis après on aura on aura le temps de
faire quelque chose sur le texte ça va
être très rapide
beaucoup de sujets le premier sujet que
je voulais évacuer que j'ai pas évoqué
évacué dans la question précédente c'est
le sujet de l'avenir de l'aise
bien évidemment dans le mandat que m'a
confié le président et la première
ministre il y avait cette question ce
sujet d'une éventuelle recentralisation
je fais partie de celle qui pense en
ayant quand même dirigé la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse que nous
mettrions 20 ans à recentraliser ou en
tout cas un certain temps à
recentraliser et que les dates n'ont pas
beaucoup témoignés non plus de leur
capacité à faire et que c'est une
politique éminemment territoriale où on
doit connaître les caractéristiques d'un
département que ce qu'elle soit sociaux
et économique parfois même historique je
pense à certains départements enfin
voilà et puis qui exige une très grande
complémentarité une coordination des
acteurs au niveau du territoire donc
personnellement je pense qu'il ne faut
pas remonter à l'état mais par contre
que l'État soit beaucoup plus présent et
quand je dis l'état de nouveau c'est des
acteurs aussi variés que la santé
l'éducation nationale la justice vous
avez tous raison la justice intervient
énormément dans ces sujets là et donc il
faut plus d'État c'est le sens du
conseil départemental de la protection
de l'enfance que vous avez adopté dans
la loi du 7 février 2022 j'aurais poussé
un peu plus pour que l'autorité
judiciaire soit mieux représentée mais
qu'importe déjà le préfet le président
du Département préfet de président du
département et autorité en présence de
l'autorité judiciaire pour on les
décrets sont en cours de finalisation
ils sont au CNPE pour faire un bilan des
besoins un bilan de l'offre une
stratégie d'offre une stratégie de
contrôle voilà mais ça ça doit être fait
au niveau du département parce qu'on
sait que dans le Nord il y a plein
d'établissements là où en Lozère il y en
a qu'un seul donc ça n'a pas de sens de
remonter ça au niveau de l'État et puis
aussi une stratégie sur les
pardonnez-moi les professionnels parce
que je pense que l'enjeu du travail
social se fait aussi au niveau du
territoire il faut être en capacité de
voir les territoires où il manque il y
en a etc et de tracer des trajectoires
professionnelles au niveau du territoire
pour moi l'avenir se joue dans le CDPE
c'est la nature d'ailleurs avec eux que
j'aie soirée la petite
contractualisation que j'ai à ma main
vous savez que j'ai un peu de fond
d'intervention régionale des ARS un peu
de ligne budgétaire et donc pour appuyer
ces projets mais je pense que que
l'avenir se joue là plus d'État et plus
d'État et c'est plus d'État dans les
contrôles d'où ma demande de renfort des
deux directions qui participent au
contrôle et qui doivent effectivement se
mobiliser sur ça la deuxième deuxième
sujet donc après on peut on est
simplement pour vous dire j'ai
parfaitement conscience qu'on est un
point de rupture aujourd'hui à l'aise
c'est à dire que le sujet des
professionnels qui sont en forte tension
fait que la qualité de la prise en
charge diminue l'absence de contrôle etc
fait qu'on a de moins en moins de
professionnels et que la qualité
diminuée et tout on est pour moi dans un
cercle vicieux où il est urgentissime
d'intervenir et de montrer par tout
moyen y compris en montrant un peu quand
même peut-être un peu les dents sur les
sujets de contrôle et c'est un peu
l'objet aussi de ce que je tente de
faire pour le moment dans dans
l'histoire de leur Eloi le sujet de la
santé très globalement sera au coeur des
Assises de la santé portés par Adrien
taquet par ailleurs qui sera pilote de
tout ça avec évidemment l'enjeu de la
santé des plus vulnérables dedans
l'enjeu de la santé scolaire parce que
on sait qu'on a un problématique de de
démographie médicale dans certains
territoires la démographie médicale dans
la santé scolaire n'est pas tellement
meilleure forme et donc la question de
l'articulation de la santé scolaire de
la PMI la santé de ville sera au cœur de
les assises qui font partie des
priorités du comité intermittériel de
l'enfance santé mentale et santé
physique des enfants
je vais te dire on pourrait en parler
toute une après-midi le sujet de la
santé mentale des enfants outre le fait
que les signaux sont extrêmement
inquiétants globalement les chiffres
qu'on avait sur les 16-18 sont passés au
13 16 tentative de suicide troubles
alimentaires etc donc on a vraiment une
grosse mobilisation à faire en sortie de
crise sanitaire probablement tout ça
potentialisé par le numérique enfin bref
les syndicateurs sont assez inquiétants
je vous rejoins il faut documenter bien
mieux parce que derrière des situations
dit de handicap mental on a plein de
situations y compris des situations de
défauts de parentalité enfin de
difficultés éducatives et on répond par
les médicaments là où il faudrait de
l'accompagnement à la parentalité ou de
l'éducation ou du social voilà on fait
du médical là où on devrait faire du
médico-social ou du éducativo
médico-social c'est tout ça était
étroitement lié
j'espère que le quinquennat nous
permettra d'agir voilà mais il faut
documenter parce que les parents se
raccrochent au fameux pédopsychiatre là
où en réalité dès le départ dans le
diagnostic etc on n'est pas bon on sait
très bien qu'un gamin aussi se comprend
très très vite il peut progresser si on
prend 6 ans plus tard c'est déjà autre
chose donc on a beaucoup de leviers mais
ils sont pas très facile
excusez-moi
je pense que il faudrait desserrer les
taux sur le nombre d'orthophonistes
parce que par exemple que les 10 se
soient médicalisés exactement quand
j'étais orthophoniste la prise en charge
des 10 c'était les orthophonistes les
orthophonistes elles-mêmes vous avez
raison parce qu'elle se dit submergée on
se comprit par des difficultés
d'acquisition du langage à cause du
téléphone enfin bref on on met des
choses diverses et variées donc bien sûr
tout le champ de la santé doit être
travaillé c'est une priorité parce que
ça impacte tout le reste ça impacte
l'École etc bon je je
pourrais parler longtemps du sujet MNA
que je connais très très bien pour
l'avoir évidemment pratiqué je peux
simplement dire que le décret mena sur
la répartition et
actuellement donc il y a publié non de
crème on voit d'être publié bon
évidemment vous avez raison la question
les sujets des MNA a contribué à
contribuer largement à l'augmentation de
l'activité de la zone
deux observations pour moi je suis assez
équilibré là-dessus un mineur quand il
est mineur sur un territoire doit être
protégé par la protection de l'enfant
voilà tout le sujet qui est en
c'est ma phrase j'ai pas dit autre chose
j'ai pas dit autre chose tant qu'il est
pas qualifié de majeur la présomption de
minorité s'impose c'est un principe pour
moi de droite qui s'impose à nous tout
l'enjeu c'est la question de
l'évaluation de la minorité sur lequel
on a beaucoup fait il y a probablement
peut-être mieux à faire
des débats sont ouverts ou pas
d'ailleurs mais voilà en tout cas en
tout cas il y a un sujet sur
l'évaluation de la minorité qui reste
hétérogène qui reste qui a été quand
même accéléré beaucoup et il y a un
sujet d'articulation entre les
dispositifs mineurs et les dispositifs
majeurs c'est à dire que voilà donc tout
ça oui je vous le confirme tout ne
relève pas de ma compétence étant chargé
des enfants même jusqu'à 21 ans oui
incontestablement après dans l'équilibre
général des flux ces enfants là doivent
être soutenus aussi et merci au
département de prendre Sacha voilà donc
on pourrait en parler très longtemps
alors il y avait quand même une question
aussi pardonnez-moi alors
la consommation de prostituées
vaste sujet évidemment
[Musique]
j'ai un côté pragmatique qui est
peut-être pas le bon voilà c'est un peu
comme vous savez l'histoire de la carte
bancaire prenons déjà ce qu'on a à
apprendre au criminel au criminel voilà
il y en a qui sont en dessous de 15 ans
voilà et faire peur en disant attention
en dessous de 15 ans c'est un crime ça
fera peut-être un peu réfléchir quand
elles ont une tête de 16 ans bah si
jamais la 15 ans je suis moi j'aime bien
faire un peu la peur du gendarme sur ce
sujet là et mais je suis de votre avis
et là pardon mais bon enfin on est dans
un pays assez complexe sur ces sujets là
sexualité ça rejoint d'ailleurs les
questions que vous avez posées sur la
question de l'éducation sexuelle enfin
voilà on a et on le voit dans les
violences faites dans les familles etc
on a un énorme enjeu sur le sujet de la
sexualité en France de l'éducation à la
vie affective et à la vie sexuelle on ne
peut que constater que un certain nombre
de signaux restent négatifs pour pas
dire inacceptable il y a un moment où il
faut quand même que les gens s'en
saisissent au-delà même des glaçons du
droit des femmes madame
elle sénatrice bien sûr on a un vrai
sujet en tout cas moi face à une
certaine montagnes si je peux avoir une
petite affaire où on chope un adulte
avec une enfant de moins de 15 ans qui
est prostituée
comptez sur moi pour aller sur les
plateaux pour dire ben voilà voilà ce
que ça voilà ou voilà on va vous m'avez
interrogé sur la mise en oeuvre de la
loi du 7 février 2022 est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise simplement que 9
décret sont très bien avancés et que on
travaille toujours et nous une nuit sur
ce sujet là et que c'est pas mal ce
qu'on fait quand même voilà bon mais
c'est une salle un vaste sujet ça va
être difficile qu'on invoque
complètement à Narbonne si tu veux dire
de mot je vais juste dire deux mots
parce que je crois ce serait dommage de
passer en 10 minutes ce que l'on voulait
dire sur la loi que qui a été votée en
février 2022 qui est qui est longue et
je voulais surtout poser des questions
sur l'application de cette loi mais en
même temps redire ce que j'ai dit
d'autre jour en séance en disant que on
ne crée pas de délégation mais il serait
intéressant de créer une mission
d'évaluation sur les lois de 2007 2016
et 2022 parce que ce qui nous pose
question c'est que on travaille sur des
lois tu as sa proposition qui a été
faite de faire ces comités
départementaux c'est le Sénat qui l'a
fait par rapport à la loi donc on a fait
beaucoup de propositions mais cette
application on ne sait pas tellement
comme elle se met en place donc j'avais
beaucoup de questions à poser il
faudrait pas le faire en cinq minutes ou
10 minutes le refaire et puis peut-être
voir si on met en place cette mission
qui paraît intéressante c'est le
rapporteur vous êtes missionné pour
faire cette mission c'est dans les
règlements du Sénat
et pour vous dire on se l'était dit
c'est pas tomber dans l'arrêt d'une
sourde je pense qu'il faut faire ce
travail les professionnels sur le
terrain attendent qu'on fasse ce travail
parce que on a beaucoup professionnalisé
ce métier de la protection de l'enfance
bon sans faire l'histoire il y a 100 ans
on était plutôt dans les institutions
religieuses on a beaucoup produit de
textes pour faire en sorte de faire de
mieux en mieux les professionnels
aujourd'hui sont un peu perdus dans
toutes nos prescriptions et je suis moi
très demandeuse de cette mission que
j'ai déjà promise à plein de monde un
peu un peu en ayant vendu la peau de
l'ours avant d'avoir tué je vous le
cacher et ça ça dépendra bien entendu
bien sûr ça n'est pas moi mais vraiment
je suis très demandé
de cet échange très intéressant j'ai
trouvé
on sent aussi
et je pense qu'en effet on est sur ces
sujets notre mission sur la protection
enfin sur les violences sexuelles une
institution avait été complétée par une
mission commune commission des lois et
commissions des affaires sociales sur la
notion de secret professionnel secret
médical secret des tout à fait
travailleurs sociaux et également un peu
le secret de la confession de l'Église
qui est un sujet tout à fait part
mais sur lequel jean-mars sauvé c'est
bien c'est bien exprimé largement du
rapport de la sieste merci beaucoup
madame ministre au plaisir de vous
recevoir à nouveau merci
non t'aurais pas dû